there's a homeless in Camp and in the
East Valley is growing and people who
live nearby say it's getting out of
control now it stretches from around
Desert Inn and Pecos to about Sahara
Nellis Loosely along the flamingo Arroyo
Trail in that area as Madison Kimbrough
reports the Clark County Commissioner
for that area is looking into it
they clean it all out a couple days
later they're all back they don't go far
they don't have anywhere to go they're
on every corner you can find tents
literally on every corner now it seems
like Lindsay who didn't want to be on
camera shares with 8 news now what she
has seen in her own community at the
Cottonwood Creek Apartment Complex along
Desert Inn those apartments right beside
the flamingo Arroyo Trail where several
homeless encampments have been set up
along with dozens of tents lining the
wash area too over in The Stonegate
community of Sunrise Manor residents
there say it's been an ongoing struggle
with the homeless invading their
property
shopping carts if you drive here and
then they're always laying around
everywhere
and especially when the course was under
construction you had a
homeless jumping over the fences you had
them in your backyards so what can be
done about this that's where Clark
County Commissioner tick Sayer Bloom
steps in after receiving several
complaints from residents now is the
time for Action people have a right to
live in peace and safety and right now
that's not happening
Bloom laying out a plan to not only make
the area safer but cleaner too with the
support of several agencies across town
next Wednesday they'll come in and start
the process to clean out the camps and
the bridge help Southern Nevada they
have teams that go out early tell the
homeless what's going to happen we're
going to try to move them out of there
and then actually close the bridge off
so you can't get back in there and do
that for a few weeks and see if that
helps Madison Kimbrough live local now
commissioner Sager Bloom says help of
Southern Nevada will give the homeless
48 hours to move their belongings before
clearing the wash and the bridge it will
Target the area over Desert Inn first